تعاون ولوم تستقبل بهما طهران مفتشين
وكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه الذين وصلوا
الثلاثاء لبحث ملفات عالقه لا تكف ايران
عن تاكيد التعاون مع الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه بموازاه رفض متجدد لما
تعتبره ضغوطا سياسيه او تنفيذا للاتفاق
النووي من طرف واحد الزياره الحاليه
لمفتشين الوكاله جاءت على وقع اتهامات
بشان اكتشاف نسب تخصيب عاليه لليورانيوم
سارع المسؤولون الايرانيون بنا فيها
مسؤولون من الوكاله موجودون في ايران
وبداوا بضيوم امس مناقشه الاتهامات
الموجهه الينا بشان كشف يورانيوم
وهذه الاتهامات ناتجه عن تقارير خاطئه من
احد مفتشي الوكاله
يوم الاحد الماضي نشرت وكاله بلومبيرج
مذكره لدبلوماسيين افادت ان وكاله الطاقه
الذريه رصدت بايران يورانيوم مخصبا بنسبه
84% وهي نسبه تقارب المستوى المطلوب لصنع
سلاح نووي اثر ذلك رد مسؤولون في وكاله
الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه ان بلادهم ملتزمه
بنسبه 60% للتخصيب وان وجود يورانيوم مخصب
بنسب تتجاوز ذلك امر طبيعي اثناء عمليه
التخصيب وان العبره بالمنتج النهائي انتقد
الطهران ما تقول انه تسييس لعمل الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه وابتعاد عن دورها
الفني تردد هذا اللوم في تصريحات وزير
الخارجيه الايراني الذي ندد ايضا بمعتبرها
رسائل متناقضه من الطرف الامريكي بشان
العوده للاتفاق النووي
مستعدون لاتمام مباحثات فيينا لكننا نتلقى
رسائل متناقضه من الطرف الامريكي تكون اي
عبر القنوات الدبلوماسيه ومتنقطه عبر
تصريحات مسؤولين امريكيين في الاعلام لوح
عبد اللهيان بما سماها الخطه باء اذا اتخذ
الطرف الامريكي وفق قوله منحا مختلفا
مؤكدا اللانيه لبلاده في امتلاك قنبله
النوويه منذ 2018 تتهم طهران الجانب
الامريكي باجهاض الاتفاق النووي حين
انسحبت منه اداره ترامب وهي تبدي طوال
الوقت ترحيبها بالعوده بشرط رفع العقوبات
والا يكون السير باتجاه اتفاق جديد غير ما
ابرم عام 2015 بينما يتهمها خصومها
بخروقات عديده للاتفاق الاصلي وبانشطه
عسكريه وسياسيه اقليميه غير مرحب بها
غربيا